what else do you want from me
what do you want me to say that's red
[Music]
all right guys as you already know
straight into it we go with a question
of the week and the question of the week
was when did you realize the
relationship was over
and as per
juicy
I'm a real emergency
[Music]
just um was it more dribble yeah
bite into a nice Peach
JCP that's juicy yeah juicy Peach
when he made physical contact and I
cringed
this is when you know the relationship
was over over not even talking stage
relationship physical contact and I
cringed just yuck get off me yuck that's
it's not actually Fair on both yes you
should have locked it I promise you my
girlfriend could never cringe when I
just touch it
am I a monster
I can't experience am I a monster I
can't experience such I apologize I
apologize I refuse rather I apologize I
refuse rather I can't experience such
when I called her and her mom answered
saying give up
bro that's the funniest one I've had in
the world
funniest response to add your question
I've had in a while just hello is is
Sharon there
give up give up give up boy
give up
I would cry my little eyes out feared
give up give up [ __ ] I looked my phone
twice thinking that's the wrong number I
lie the mum but who is this because we
wouldn't know from the jump you wouldn't
know from the job who is this yeah
anyway
he was eating me out and I couldn't stop
thinking about getting my brake pads
changed
she just wasn't present bro I've been
there been there I have been there fam
I've been getting slopped in my life
just by pit person I don't care yeah
yeah I've been thinking brav
o I wonder what you guys doing right now
[Music]
oh Abby my phone would be vibrating and
I'd be thinking
I bet it wasn't just pop it
I wonder what food that's doing right
now
foreign
because I'm obviously getting slot but
what's he doing
wow
and then I'm just at the same time I'm
just there like uh
I'm just wrong you have to kind of fake
it to make it kind of thing and it's
it's
coming up Michael Jackson
oh my
god oh yeah I feel like everyone's been
there bro yeah right it's tough
he carved my name on his chest when I
said I wasn't feeling it anymore
carved it carved
I'm not I'm not feeling this anymore I
said swear swear I'm bleeding for you
literally from drapes the knife and just
like carving names jelly no no no no no
no no no no just writing across the
chest
stop Insanity listen stop Insanity I'd
scream yeah
a scream I promise you I wouldn't get
the first initial done
I don't care how much I love her I will
draw for it I'll get probably the first
bit of the initial I'd be like wow wow
what am I doing wow that hurts
that's permanent because wow facts facts
all right when did you realize the
relationship was over when I cried in
front of her
manhood was gone he knew and I cried
when I cried in front of him he couldn't
hold it back yeah released a few tears
and looked up and said yeah is that
because he saw her eyes
and he was like oh it's dark it's
actually right it's actually a wrap this
isn't a safe space and I can't be
vulnerable and you've made that clear
there's actually a wrap I don't know a
group chat right now yes I mean on her
phone as we speak as on Christ I'm
crying she's in the group chat saying
this is done this is done he's a [ __ ]
my ex was crying in front of my face and
over my man my ex imagine seeing that on
the phone I couldn't imagine imagine you
cry yeah she consoles you everything she
goes to toilet I'll get you some tissue
yeah and you see you're looking you're
looking you see her phone on the bed
what's that still open it says I just
saw my ex cry
you've not even told me this the dance
is done I just saw my ex cry and they
all know she's talking about you
because they saw cry and x and thought
cool it has to be it's no there's no
other person yeah why is he crying
oh
ask my ex I just saw my ex cry
I would have to confront her
I would have to confront and be like why
obviously I'm crying I thought this was
a safe space but now you've gone and
made it
seem as if I'm an [ __ ] like I'm a
waste man and then you're calling me an
ex already yeah you've not even said
anything to me to me I like but are you
breaking up with me and everyone else
knows about me the yeah the community
knows that I'm an ex before I know I'm
an ex that's that can't run and it can't
stop fam but the thing is the more you
confront her about it the more she'll
act like you're gonna cry again
does that means
she's like I did I couldn't tell you I
had to tell them before I told you yeah
because you're just crying you're just
gonna cry again that's all you're gonna
you're just gonna cry again like the
crybaby you are that's why you're my ex
you cry that's that's what you're known
for
this is what you'll know the first time
you cried today
your first time ever shed his teeth
you're renowned for crying so how was I
supposed to tell you we're done because
you're just gonna be crying you're just
gonna cry all over my carpet yeah I had
to wait until you leave so I could tell
you it's done because you're a little
[ __ ] a little baby
you ran out for crying
that's what you do this one is so dread
when I open up a Snapchat from him and
it was a girl laughing at me
imagine receiving a snap a purple snap
from the love of your life you're
thinking oh I can't wait to see what
this is you leave it for seven minutes
so you don't seem too yeah yeah yeah
yeah you've seen the notification time
ago time ago but you play bro you play
it [ __ ] cool you open it up and it's
just another yeah laughing
laughing at you bro well in your case
would be another brother laughing at you
on her snap she's not even in it no
they're just walking down the road and
he's just like this angled
send it to you like that with that level
of chance that level of chest he's dead
he's dead I'll say put the location
thing on there where where are you at on
the map
facts I'll swipe I already know she's on
the map I'll swipe and find her find her
and find him I'm finding this mobile
yeah he's dying his liver's dumb
laughing
yo that's that's not funny yeah this is
my heart we're talking about but I know
Amanda would never do that factual man
they would never do that in fact because
it's just irrelevant stuff that's that's
a galley take Pam every time a guy hears
what a waste like every time a side man
hears about from the girl how waste her
man is he doesn't want to hear it he
gets defensive for him yeah I'm not here
for that yeah because this room is our
Dynamic yeah it's women's our Dynamic
I'm only here for the knot I'm here for
the nut don't speak about in my facts I
don't want to hear his name whilst I'm
in this yard and that's how it should
remain
anyway when she asked me if cheesecake
contained Dairy oh one million percent
get the [ __ ] out my face idiot when she
walked by me naked and I couldn't have
cared less
fam couldn't have cared less
relationship's done relationship is done
fam I couldn't just be playing just
check and just know for like [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] about your titties
your ass your face your lips put some
clothes on yeah please you're not even a
distraction that's embarrassing for you
you're not even distracting me wow I'm
lasered in I'm focused I don't care oh
man that's that's painful mad when she
gossip to her family in her mother
tongue by Dan Duolingo
so he clocked it all clocked it all
when I feel like this all Vex you oh
okay when the cereal was put back far
less than ample serve inside
oh fan
I swear down that's
Fighting 100 that is fire talk you put
the whole box of cereal in there and
this is how do you know how I know it
was empty because you didn't even bother
folding in yeah yeah folding in the back
the back you didn't scramble the bag up
it's just open
only three spoonfuls that's all you got
um oh bro just I pour it and it's just
dust there's there's three churros and
dust
oh yeah 100 100 that's over
when I started deleting his messages as
soon as he sent them just receive swipe
delete receive swipe deleted this is
your current man current
wow people are treacherous in these
streets wow let's have a conversation
bro I'll just delete my messages to me
let's hash it out and we're together
tell me why you don't like me yes so I
can figure out my next step yeah do you
know what I mean
I need to figure out where I'm going
yeah where am I sleeping tonight
how deep is this thanks
when he wore orange Crocs to a formal
event wow Jesus a bright boy when our
families found our nudes on each other's
phones
so the relationship's over over not even
by choice they must be kids kids are
Muslims either or both
or God forbid both
[Laughter]
hilarious
when I found out he was sleeping with
his ex me and his now wife at the same
time is next as well bro ex girls even
when let's go what's the bar I just seen
my ex-girl starting with my next girl
standing with the girl that I'm [ __ ]
right now Jesus Christ yeah one of them
ones speak and he's now current wife
peek bro
sore toilet paper in his butt crack
while he grabbed his boxes
while he grabbed these boxes how is man
sliding on boxes with his body showing
like that he just bent over just in
front of her just
just balls of tissue in the hairs just
in the hairs
[ __ ] you know oh look like [ __ ]
antennae bam I'm vomiting oh if I'm hurt
um sometimes though I don't understand
how women can see a naked figure of a
man and not throw up
do you know what I mean I know exactly
what you mean because I only want to be
naked in front of a woman once we're
having sex or pre-sex sex and literally
10 seconds posted my oh at least my box
is on put 10 seconds post sex I slide my
things down when we're in the covers
yeah and I make sure throughout the
session I can feel with my foot yeah
wherever they are
where they are in fact my box is all my
sleepy time shorts
I can feel at all times no matter what
position I know where they're at that's
hilarious I Dash right on the floor
because you might not be done here
they're getting slid back up
because you're not seeing me compromise
like that compromise because I don't I
like what we're doing yeah yeah yeah
like in the morning we're not here
Frank you'd run away yeah yeah I never
sleep you can pay me to sleep naked
that's hilarious
uh leading on to this when he would go
to bed in just a T-shirt and no boxes
that's impossible
a T-shirt and no boxes
why
why he wants freedom but he's cold it
doesn't make any sense that's the worst
thing I've heard this makes no sense
that's when she knew the relationship
was over all right that's when he got he
got comfortable comfortable she said
babe to be fair he's obviously get in
there with boxes and t-shirts they said
to be found I'm just not comfortable and
it slide them up and that was the
experiment he wanted to see you yeah she
didn't care she secretly did care and
then he just started rocking up in
Walking in the bedroom with just dick
out and just a challenge t-shirt the
T-shirt probably just went literally
just just literally
it's self little helmet just under the
T-shirt Man fight me fight everyone
because that's a no-go that's so
disgusting when she said when she said
love G when I told her she looked nice
love G on a spud thing I say that to
mandem you look like oh babe you look
nice
I Promise You The Weave will get torn so
vigorously from your scalp love G love G
who else are you talking to we're going
home who else are you talking to no no
we're going home and you're going to get
changed I don't care where we're going
because you're gonna if you're gonna
speak to me like tracksuit you're gonna
wear it
because you're clearly trying to look
nice for someone else and I've refused
to be a party to it
if you speak to me like tracksuit you're
gonna wear a tracksuit facts that's
jokes I couldn't love G I'll cry my eyes
out for her oh baby the love of my life
tonight love G love G I'm trying to look
beautiful for next man my world would be
rattled right she would experience such
an overreaction from me oh ragos that's
the most respectful thing I've I've
heard the thing is I don't even feel
like it would be an overreaction it will
probably will just be a reaction I've
never experienced this do you know what
I mean so it would be new to me as well
yeah it won't be an overreaction you
haven't felt bubbles in your blood level
ever ever bro how dare you that's that
is literally the definition of being
told like she might as well saying
I'd like I'm with someone else like
that's why you're answering me like I'm
saying babe you look really nice to that
and she's like you're not my boyfriend I
have another boyfriend I have a not even
another I have a boyfriend we're boys
now yeah yeah we're me and you are boys
now I have a man yeah I have a man I
have a man who I love who I love and me
you are just boys you're just a guy you
are just a guy you're just here take it
or leave stop speaking you're just here
love G love love G digest it love G full
stop
sharp now and drive
take it to him ah take me to him yeah
long
when he called the police when I tried
to see him
man said don't you dare come over I'm
gonna call the police
she tried to rock up
who's going through that at the minute
lady leash you see
she bit him
I forgot about that she bit him that was
a few weeks back yeah she bit a scratch
man or something like that in like 2 A.M
no you're not biting me she was
handcuffed
she was handcuffed in the middle of the
night that was tough that was tough oh I
was tough when he called the police when
I tried to see him don't you dare come
over she's crazy
she's crazy and she will never admit
yeah that's all the red flags that's all
the red flags
when I realized his hands were smaller
than mine
that's a huge red flag forget
huge red
flags were smaller than mine girl sounds
are small they're tiny girls hands are
small they're tiny they're tiny
they need to be strong if there's
someone that need to be happy
Forum strengthen the grip and calluses
yeah yeah you're TR all you do is
Tradesman and I work hard
facts I labor for this life back swag
swags
when he splattered watermelon all over
my front door and glued weave to my car
what did you do what did you do first
family
first because that's a retaliation facts
what did she do she must have done some
glued weave to the car that doesn't even
make sense it doesn't even make sense
when I walked in on him wiping his ass
standing up oh Jesus Christ standing up
James
I would have to tell the straight like
yeah we're done like if you're walking
in on me and I'm standing up wiping my
ass and you're like oh [ __ ] I would say
whoever doesn't live here leave
I'm standing up yeah that means he must
have spread his cheek with one hand and
then yeah yeah yeah no like found some
levels yeah yeah on the bar for
something what to really get in there
what was he really looking for
you know what I mean why is he trying to
gain so much I can only imagine he was
getting really frustrated with just how
wet it was
you must have done a little wet that's
right first White then it slipped off
she was like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] and you know
when like you don't fold it you just
scrunch it
get the [ __ ] off my hand yeah yeah and
you wrap the next one around your
knuckles you wrap it around your
knuckles
and you wipe again it slips off again
and you're like [ __ ]
this was a [ __ ] this was a [ __ ] Jesus
and then you you're thinking in your
head am I not done yeah you stop and
think am I not done and you test your
bowels yeah I am done yeah yeah and you
go for one more it's still wet and
you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] and then he's he's
standing up now he stood up now he's
like this is this is too Jared
this is too jarring it's a shower all
yeah he probably stood up to look in the
toilet like what's going on
is take it as if it even came out
[ __ ] hell there are a few more he ate
my ass guessing it was his last attempt
to save the relationship it was the last
straw
it was the last straw she wasn't about
it
she wasn't about stuff like that too
little too late too little too late you
might ask now after what you did the
last straw so jokes man was literally
clutching at straws he was picking on
anything he wanted it he wanted anything
to save it yeah oh your ass too little
too late oh that's hilarious when he
stopped going down on me because his
tongue hurts
I'm about jaw rake sometimes oh thanks
I've set it on here before like there
are times where I'm eating out and if
the thighs are nice and juicy I just
rest my head I just rest my head lick
like I'm like I'm a cat drinking milk
facts bro
like I'm a cat drinking milk brother I
have to my neck hurts and my jaw's tired
but I love what I'm doing do you know
what I mean I don't want to stop I love
it here this is home but yeah this is
home but I just want to relax I want to
give me your bendy give me your
beautiful that's
facts bro
oh [ __ ]
cat drinking
[Laughter]
very hard
oh [ __ ]
oh my stomach's hurting now
oh [ __ ]
oh please continue
please continue fine I'm not gonna lie
the last four sentences was pause pause
pause pause
you had please continue please no my
stomach hurts oh right please please
continue
you're in my guts hahaha
for the audio listeners he's in my gas
hilarious oh that's a joke last one
going whilst he's golf no sorry whilst
his girlfriend opened the door
his girlfriend opened the door with a
key whilst we were eating breakfast
with a key
me and her are just eating breakfast
eating breakfast girl walks in with a
kid fam I can't be eating breakfast with
potential said love in my life bam and I
hear Jingles on the door I'm like babe
who's
hey how many how many other people live
here yeah and you're not gonna and fam
as the man as soon as you heard that
as it entered the little thing
his world fell out he knows he's
everything is done everything is done
he's looking at Exit points oh Rago
Rago he's his yard he's gonna leave her
in there yeah this is why like dogs need
to be millionaires because he needs to
know as soon as she opens that door he
can run out in just a close on his back
and his keys his car keys and he doesn't
have to think about it again you can
just start again start a new life let
the missus and the inciting deal with it
I'm not dealing with it let them deal
with that I'm not dealing with any of
that so as I hear that key coming I need
to be I need an exit point
and I'm out and I'm not thinking about
this again ever again you can you lock
and message me as much as you like you
man hash it out between yourselves
whatever red emoji faces you want
I'm changing my number I'm changing my
name change my name I'm not I've got
time for this oh [ __ ] it up but yeah
that was the um question of the week
guys that was top six five six yeah six
add your questions I've had that's jokes
that's hilarious well done on that one
that one was [ __ ] funny right safe
so guys welcome back welcome to the show
um got a lot of uh good feedback last
week about uh obviously the new cameras
and the setup and stuff like that and we
are still dealing with a little piece of
echo in here it's a big space we're
caked now and we threw money at a
situation without thinking of the
logistics yeah yeah so
bear with us by next week it'll be
sorted hopefully
um but anyway guys welcome back happy to
have you here what we need you to do
right now is pause the episode and head
on over please if you will to
patreon.com forward slash shits and
games guys now why are we asking you to
do that well how about this every
Thursday this episode that you're gonna
get right here you're gonna get another
one I know you guys like to binge
through the episodes
and then you you you feel you're you've
had your fill and there's nothing
nowhere else to go and the days become
weeks and you're stressed thanks well
we're telling you for a little three
pound a month 10p a day you can run the
pizza sng and you can get an extra
episode every Thursday plus the years of
other episodes that we've done on
patreon all exclusive
no ads no censorship nothing all the
good stuff is over there on patreon guys
so head on over there and on top of that
become a true member of the cult babies
okay a true member in our Log Cabin a
true member with the white robes where
your cult daddies and you be a cult baby
and you get to get together on our
Discord Channel with all the other
thousands of cult babies who just chin
wag every day to Mike every day is Peng
so getting over there guys
patreon.comgigs and as always guys if
you are new to the Channel Please
Subscribe like the video if you like the
video and Shout to Ting in the comments
if you will see if you play
um and last but not least Guys audio
listeners thank you for sticking with us
please leave a nice review if you can it
uh means the world for us five stars is
preferable but whatever you need to say
say it with your chest give us what we
deserve guys and without any further Ado
my comrade my Confidant my dark skin
daddy Fire Lord fakes is gonna hit us
with the fun fact of the day educate us
wigs let's go right scientists in Japan
are close to discovering a cure for
boldness after growing fully mature hair
follicles in a lab
do you know what the piss take is what I
don't know how many people said that to
me
you think it's a game
you think I'm joking well they know how
many people because they know every
story so they're probably help it's not
you receive it as a mistake you because
they are taking a miss out on me yeah
they are and they're not
they're trying to help me they're trying
to help you in there because you
complain about it week and week out I do
complain about it I had a new Barber
come see me the other day yeah yeah um
and he was like oh your hairline's
strong and I was like giddy
I was just like
well you know
it's all right yeah yes it's right yeah
um but yeah
he did a good job as well yeah he did he
was nervous he wouldn't be first first
trailer with a new brother in my own
yard oh yeah yeah I forgot it came to my
yard so if I hate it who's going
anywhere yeah who's going anywhere
because he'll ask how is it and I'll be
like to be honest I don't like it and
he'll be like sit back down it's fine
and he's not he's refusing to leave yeah
yeah and he has to fix it he has to fix
it you have to fix it because I want to
come back on a weekly basis I'm a
perfectionist yeah and I do I'm not
happy and I want you to leave that was
all the scenarios that were going
through he knows where you live now yeah
and he knows what the address and you're
like bro let's just let it grow out and
I can come back and I'm like start
Baba
stop because this is yeah yeah yeah it's
fine I'll go back to my old Papa this is
force yeah and you're scaring me
facts so yeah luckily found it nice I
was like all right cool it's okay
oh [ __ ] um but yeah yeah let me read
this thing
um a cure a cure for bonus could be on
the horizon after scientists generate
hair follicles in a lab a team from uh
Yokohama National University grew mature
follicles with long shafts Farm
follicles with what long shafts
apparently
um they also improved hair follicle
color after adding a drug that boosted
melanin and natural pigment
the technique involves creating skin
organoids tiny simple versions of an
organ in a pet in a petri dish
organized we're in were promising tool
to elucidate the mechanisms in hair
follicles in vitro says uh tatsuto
kagayama I like that name and an
assistant professor irrelevant stuff so
hair loss effects up to two to five two
in five men there's four men in there
two in five two in five man
I look at Ellis
[Music]
I'm just gonna throw it out there
he's gone for a minute
I can't look at myself I have to look at
someone else
I have to look at someone else as I was
saying hair loss affects two in five men
going bold can harm mental health for
both men and women
no
for both men and women
that's atrocious
going bold can harm mental health for
both men and women scientists have long
sought a cure for baldness with many
people with many people turn into hair
loss treatments and supplements for help
but yeah
I'm not gonna lie when you start getting
into the nitty-gritty you're just saying
stuff to me
and I was getting frustrated I don't
know what you're saying what this vitro
follicles shafts there's no one so they
create or they get these hair follicles
and they create them in
um in Petri dishes okay
I think they just so it's a transplant
without taking it from the thing I feel
like that's what it is
well to grow it back yeah don't be
stabbing my head give me a drug
um but yeah anyway
I've got um a quick movie recommendation
okay hit me I feel like you've told me
about it before so I'm sorry if you have
but if you have we can talk about it
okay the goodness
I don't even think I've heard of that
gang cool say less okay it's new on
Netflix okay it's a true story okay it's
about
um have to give props to the main actor
um can't remember his name but he's the
guy from
he played Stephen Hawkins in the Stephen
Hawkins movie oh the English brother
from he plays yeah I know exactly who he
is but I don't know his name I know
exactly who you're talking about exactly
who you're talking about yeah actor
actor you know exactly who you're
talking about him terrifying human
Famsa is about a true story it's a
[ __ ] true story about a nurse that
was uh going into hospitals and just
straight
murdering people okay how he was
injecting insulin into them
yeah okay okay he was injecting insulin
into the bags and like um
yeah so he would stab it you know the
ivy bag yes he would just stab it stab
inside and it would drip and he'll just
like and the thing is he didn't even
know he didn't even have a specific
Target so when they kept where they kept
all the insulin all the IV bags you just
pick one stab it and whoever gets that
bag dead
so he had no there was no motivation for
he just once at the end they said why
did you do it he said they just never
stopped me they
fam they just never stopped oh wow and
basically what was happening is the
story follows him
and some some uh a fellow nurse that he
was working with a girl and um
basically
people he was doing the night shifts
he's a lovely guy Everyone likes him of
course it was the night shift that makes
sense night shift everyone loves him
nice guy and he got into a proper proper
close friendship with this this woman
okay and fam as soon as he started
people just started dying as soon as he
started at this Hospital okay okay
people just started dying okay code
Blues everywhere okay resuscitation
thing everywhere okay and it was
happening so often and people were just
like what's going on so they had a
criminal investigation
and what happened was is the hospital
were covering up
so the police came in and were like cool
we've been called about this like
um
this death that we feel like um and
obviously the hospital called the police
in and the police were like all right
cool so what details have you got oh
we've not really got any details we've
just got like a few bits and Bobs and
like all right cool like can we see the
body so are the body's been cremated and
the police were like cremated like how
long ago did she die yeah it was like
seven weeks ago he's like so why are you
Belling me today oh yeah why don't you
build me seven weeks ago we were doing
our own internal investigation and we're
like okay so what information have you
got for this internal investigation and
they gave him like one sheet of A4 paper
I was like that's it it's like this is
seven weeks of Investigation so the
police got immediately that the hospital
was trying to cover it up oh facts I was
trying to cover it up so basically what
was happening is he will go in
they were clocked they knew it was him
as soon as they saw him not as soon as
they saw him but when these things are
happening yeah they knew it was him but
the hospital didn't want to get
um sued for malpractice so what that
would happen he's killing all these
people but the hospital wouldn't uh
doing anything about it because if they
fired him or if they contacted the
police saying this guy's killing people
yeah
the victims the families of hospitals
through the hospital because to him
they'll see the hospital so the hospital
paying out millions and millions they
kind of that's a reputation and in
America these are hospitals are
privately owned yeah it's not like an
NHS tank here like so
instead of them getting sued they will
just they'll fire him for anything
they'll just call him into a meeting and
anything that they can find to firing on
so one would be like oh
um on your app when you start here your
application said you started in um you
started your last job in June but I
called your last job and they said you
started in May and he's like okay he's
like bro you lied on your contract like
you're gone oh okay so there was a fire
but he would just move the police found
did a digging on him he'd worked at nine
different hospitals every single
hospital did the same thing they just
sacked him left him sacked him for
nothing let him go get another job at
different hospitals someone else's
problem they just as long as he's not
killing people not family that's exactly
what he meant they just didn't stop me
wow so go in there people are dying
dying dying dying the hospital will do
their investigation find out with him
sack him for something irrelevance to
stop himself getting sued he'd go very
next day walk over to the closest next
Hospital same job killing killing
killing killing but sacked how is he
getting
obviously he's getting sacked from One
hospital going to another hospital
surely he's gonna need a reference how
the [ __ ] is he getting arrested in a
reference they um
they'll just uh they'll just call the
hospital and say oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah of course of course
yeah and the hospital
um when the people that are doing the
references are not the people that
caught the people that were sacking him
with a high high up in the hospital yeah
they're not going to give a reference
they're not doing the reference this is
yeah yeah they're doing a reference they
don't know who he is they don't know
anything about him they just can check
the records yeah he did work here bless
factual and he was sat and they're like
oh he was let go for [ __ ] lime on his
they said he went these days when he
actually got these days
um so if I'm yeah he went to Bear
hospitals wow that's a true story it's a
true story the guy's still depend now
the real guy oh I would like to believe
so [ __ ] movie [ __ ] hell slow but a
movie okay one of them ones yeah it's so
quiet a movie because he's not he's not
he's not killing people with aggression
oh yeah okay he plays a very timid like
quiet a bit Camp
um
like nurse is it does it really struck
this year yes all right since it's like
number one in films right now oh so just
just came out on Netflix okay okay okay
um oh God I couldn't believe it
um just a spin off from that obviously
the last time you spoke about
um or the last time I spoke about any um
Apple TV show was the For All Mankind oh
yeah I remember I said it was like three
episodes in
and they were doing up trying to find
ice and all this stuff yeah I finished
season one the show [ __ ] develops
swear now I know why these men have said
for all mankan is the Apple TV show
James is a [ __ ] show
for all my candy is a [ __ ] show swear
swear stop I don't want to spoil
anything but I just need to tell you
James you have to watch this show you
have to watch this show it's slow
between like episodes one and three
maybe one or four but it's so relevant
because just for just for a quick catch
up guys I don't know if I spoke about on
last week's app or what patreon app yeah
you did For All Mankind
but it's a race to space between
obviously the Americans and the Soviets
the Soviets got their first Americans
when they're after then a service put
I've got women on the moon first then so
did Americans they're the Americans
spotted there was ice on the moon
because they wanted to use ice for
potential Rocket Fuel to get further out
in space blah blah so when
um when the Americans made their base in
they call it Jamestown they call their
base James sign in on the moon when they
made their base there to try and find
the ice they found the ice but they saw
they saw their Ops basically there as
well
um which are the Soviets they saw them
on the other side of the one crater that
where this ice was
but throughout like
episode one to like maybe like episode
seven wait you don't see any Sofia you
just see tracks and [ __ ] you see
evidence that they're about yeah yeah
yeah but bro there's so much stuff that
happens on the moon as well as so much
politics and [ __ ] that happens on earth
that is fuckeries so the main brother is
called Ed he um he like commands
Jamestown he him and a couple of people
went up
and um his misses
um obviously is on Earth and his son
his son is one of those ones where
because these pops has been in space
these pops have been in space for five
months or two other people five months
because they couldn't get um they
couldn't get a um
an exchange like for other people to
come up with so they can come down
because there was a conspiracy because
one of the
um Rockets I was going to go up and I
was meant to replace them exploded why
did it explode so they were digging into
some stuff they were digging in some
stuff so they said all the other flights
not going up that are going to be
unmanned so we can't replace you you
have these must start losing their minds
so they've got um they've only had like
two or three videos that they can watch
and when I say they've watched it over
and over so they knew it they knew the
video like for entertainment purposes
they knew the video because they'd been
watching it so now it's it's available
to like a psychological Thriller well
they've been watching it so there was a
point where let's forget Ed about for
now there's a brother called Gordo
Gordon yeah but they called him Gordo he
loses his nut bro oh I can imagine and
Ed says you can't leave James the the
base James out I'm not letting you go
outside anymore because you're you're
acting crazy you're acting crazy this
this man wakes them up in the middle of
the night one time
come on come on come on it's time to act
it's time to act because yeah because
the [ __ ] tape breaks so they've got
nothing to watch so it's
um Gorda was saying all the parts and
sitting on all the seats
but he's axing it all up because he's
got nothing to it in the morning he's
waking up about two in the morning to
act it all out [ __ ] he's losing his
mind bro Jesus [ __ ] Christ but
there are some scenes that are just
fantastic because you don't see much
about like in terms of like the gravity
and space or the anti-gravity in space
until like episode five or so but the
way they bring it in is just beautiful
so let's I'm gonna watch it bro it's
it's the production value yeah when
they're in space is fantastic gonna
watch it fantastic you've sold me
um because yeah that sounds juicy and
there's literally everyone says there's
a chick called Molly
hardboard my my size no no no not in
that not even in that context but she
you okay
that's all I must say fam um side note
I'm feeling chainsaw man oh goodness me
who is it who isn't
who is a chainsaw man who [ __ ] what's
the show what happened on episode what
are you up to you up today yeah like
four what is it now episode four I'm not
seeing four I think I've only seen three
then I don't think I'm up today
um I'm pretty sure I've seen the third
the third one where um him and I can't
remember her name went to went to the
yards and then they yeah that's the
third one found the demon what's the
fourth one yeah yeah I don't think I've
seen
[Music]
he loves tits in it oh that's he will do
anything for repair tits
before you'll see that in episode he
risks it all for for a little fondle oh
everything yeah yeah and I'm so forth
wow wow yeah he's crazy loses his mind
what's his name Genji yeah yeah denji
denji yeah loses his mind for them
um
obviously still been watching blue lock
been watching bleach I've been watching
my hero
um anime's up at the minute it really is
I haven't started from psycho I don't
know if I can I found I found the last
season really boring yeah
until like the end was the end of season
two where a lot of them fought like two
or three brothers yeah and there was one
that one but it was teleported
that was season two yeah yeah that end
of that season was like that was hard
the last two three episodes of season
two were unbelievable yeah yeah first
like seven or eight were God oh that's
why I stopped that's the reason why I
stopped I remember I remember I stopped
watching mob psycho season two for a
reason because it was trash it was so
boring fam incredibly so boring but I
think there's like four reps of season
three out now I've only seen I think
I've seen the first three all right but
it's just one of like same with season
one and same with season two it's a slow
burner until though yeah bro
it's okay all right so just okay um so
I'm looking forward cool okay guys time
for a tiny little break to keep our very
expensive lights on and the way we are
gonna do that is tell you guys educate
you guys indoctrinate you guys into the
manscaped way of life guys so it's never
too early to play holiday music it's
never too early to think about gifts
whether it's for a friend or for the
friends in your pants
you can make this a season to be jolly
with manscape guys do your little
drummer boy a favor and use the
lawnmower 4.0 to avoid another silent
night in the bedroom Jesus then Adam
Landscapes top of the line shower
products to have people thinking all I
want for Christmas is you come on
Santa cares about your sack and so
should you facts look nice when you get
naughty by going to man escaped.com guys
and if you want 20 off plus free
shipping use the code sng zero November
golf sng's the code guys 20 off free
shipping maskscape.com let's get back to
the episode
um so I've got trash news Okay quick one
on this one
did you see uh James corden's under the
the chopping block again two weeks in a
row why no so obviously last week he was
um in beef because of the restaurant
thing yes uh made a fool of himself at a
restaurant yeah and he came out and
apologized did you see that no so he did
an apology and explained the story not
gonna like a live ticket
okay did a whole thing on his show I'm
not gonna lie
I think I know what you want to say
about the second thing but continue cool
yeah continue I think I do because I saw
some but I didn't read into it yeah yeah
yeah I didn't read into it at all so
he's um he's a thief basically stealing
stuff yeah say less mum's the worst
he's stealing people's stuff that's what
I'm hearing that's why Mary tell my
story
I remember it all I continue yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so don't spoil it for these men okay
talk talk so obviously he did an apology
on his uh his Late Late Show okay and
was like he spun I don't know the
narrative fam he's a I can tell he's a
liar and a cheat okay just the way that
his story is completely different to the
restaurant manager story really
completely different oh he's a master
manipulative because it's compelling as
well oh he's trying to put on
heartstrings he said my wife's got a
[ __ ] he's like because the
restaurant's called Balthazar in it
Balthazar because uh me and my wife and
some friends we went to Battlestar he
said I love Balthazar I love it the food
the people the service the atmosphere I
love it there that's why I'm always
there that's like say less you are there
a lot
um that's the word on the street yeah
you do like it there yeah yeah okay and
then he basically said about the um The
Omelette he was like oh my wife's got a
[ __ ] food allergy okay so she can't
have egg whites okay so they bought it
out he said the thing was wrong and then
he said after it come out wrong the
third time I'm made an insensitive joke
and said maybe I should go in there and
cook it myself he was like I shouldn't
have said that it was rude I was
frustrated etc etc the way you spun it I
say spun he could be right he could be
but yeah the way he said I was thinking
oh it's a good narrative to play
incredibly good narrative but he was
like I'm so sorry Etc it never happened
again I need to check myself
um
now yeah now he's come out again because
he got caught stealing Ricky gervais's
joke yeah word for word see I saw that
title and I saw a bit literally a little
bit of video but I didn't actually watch
the video so yeah it's um it's a bit
we're talking about like uh people being
like oversensitive and stuff like that
okay and the bit is about
um
it's like um I think it was about when
people get offended
I think the joke because I can't
remember the context of the joke but
I've seen the wreckage of a special and
if I remember correctly I could be
completely wrong so forgive me guys if
I'm wrong but I'm pretty sure the
narrative or the premise of the joke is
people getting offended on behalf of
other people okay so if I say if I'm
like oh this person's fat and that you
turn to me and and get physically angry
with me and because you can't say fat
yeah yeah you can't say fat like okay
you're being offensive but you're not
fat okay so and the the thing is is like
it's exactly and then the Rick of a
stroke is like basically saying that's
like going to like walking down the
street seeing a poster for piano lessons
and being like
I don't [ __ ] want piano lessons
you're like because fine like you don't
have that PMS this is for people who do
it yeah I don't [ __ ] want piano
lessons yeah um so basically and
something that was something along the
lines of the joke but then yeah uh James
Corden I'm assuming we'll talk about the
same topic and said the exact joke he
didn't even because the the joke that
Ricky said was guitar lessons Okay James
Corden didn't even change the type of
lesson he said guitar lessons he said
word for word the exact same thing wow
the exact same thing
two weeks in a row that's poor task poor
PR it fast or PR because he would have
saved himself with the initial stuff or
like trying to pluck on hard strings or
whatever the same week is doing up
apology he's getting caught for stealing
next man's Joe
boruto
damn I don't know how he's gonna dig
himself out of this one I mean he's
gonna have to he's gonna he's gonna have
to he's gonna have to take it he's on TV
every week that's the thing but the
thing is as well as like usually people
when they're in this situations will say
stuff like oh like I just took
inspiration I'm a massive Ricky
gervaised fan I wasn't even I didn't
even know but the fact that he said word
for word like not not even a young
paraphrase or nothing nothing was
paraphrased exactly the same thing oh
wow same energy same time in same
everything the whole thing was the same
so I was like that you can't even say
that that's the same thing
um it's long for him
unfortunately it's long for him the game
is the game um so I've got one more as
well okay which is
um
I saw a I saw a flipping
tweet that basically said hang on
you might have seen this use of the
n-word on Twitter jumped up by almost
500 after Elon Musk take over I actually
didn't see that fam so trolls test their
limits on free speech
um
Elon Musk bought Twitter yeah yeah I've
seen that yeah yeah we're not doing
censorship we're not doing calcium fam
these men just said yeah Twitter ninja
ninja ninja ninja ninja ninja ninja
ninja [ __ ] hell it's mad like Twitter
yeah I remember when when it happened I
think it was last week or so Bella was
telling me Oh have you seen Twitter
recently I was like well go and she said
there's just hate on there now because
of free speech she was saying like
there's pictures and shot of Hitler oh
[ __ ] really oh obviously
her Twitter is going to be different to
my Twitter and blah blah blah yeah yeah
I was like Wow talking about Jews
talking about this talking about that
it's like I mean this is what Elon Musk
wanted clearly because in fact it's free
speech you can't get what or cancel
every speech so this is the narrative
he's playing it is I think the thing is
whether I think I'm I'm pretty sure
they're keeping in I could be again
completely wrong I think it's Free
Speech but without hate speech
so stuff like dropping the n-word being
anti-semitic being like
um
yeah like transphobic being homophobic
stuff I hate I don't think hate speech
is allowed but like free speech is
allowed and I feel like this that and
the other you can say what you want yeah
but like hey actually saying I hate Jews
or something like that bro bro that's
that kind right it can't Twitter it's
wild no yeah it's wild now obviously
you're hearing about he wants to charge
I think is it eight dollars per
verification or whatever I heard it's 20
or 20 I think twenty dollars a month 20
a month yeah but I think I've seen sign
ups that's changed drop down to eight or
something like that anyway there is I
saw the 21 as well what are your
thoughts on that what the verification
of 20 a month I don't mean I'm not gonna
lie I have no thought yeah I generally
have no thought about it I saw it and I
didn't care yeah yeah that was literally
my honest answer yeah honestly I saw it
I didn't really care um obviously but I
think it's like apparently
um I don't know if this is the case on
other platforms but apparently it is in
the Twitter algorithm if you're verified
on Twitter your [ __ ] will get boosted
more okay that's a fact okay if you're
verified on there you will get better
like okay
um views and stuff like that so like it
makes sense to be charged to charge um
it does make sense it literally makes
sense to charge people
um to to keep their back I think it's
being verified on Twitter is not
like
um
it's not necessary for anything in your
life so it should be like a privilege so
if it's charged like I don't see why
people would have a massive issue about
it um but again
I literally don't care I I couldn't I
couldn't care less I don't care I
honestly don't care um okay cool I've
got um who said you wanted to have a
chat was that the mankind thing oh no no
I've got something else to you
so I had this was on Monday
um a really really wholesome moment a
really wholesome wholesome moment on
Monday okay let me yeah let me let me
paint the whole picture okay okay I'm
ready so I was actually those yard we
were chilling we're playing UFC get
happy played it before no I haven't it's
good this game is good the fluid it's
nice it's fluid it's like hard that's
the whole reason I've never really got
into it because it looks like it
wouldn't be fluid it's good okay but
it's hard though like [ __ ] you know it's
hard yeah so we were
sad yeah um so we were chilling playing
UFC playing UFC and all of a sudden my
um my phone started ringing I saw it was
my Pops I suppose that I went outside to
his balcony I was speaking before I
answered the call I was like
uh just general chicha how are you blah
blah blah and he said I'll watch your
new video your new episode and he said I
love the new production I love the new
production I was like oh my God thank
you so much and he said he couldn't word
for what he couldn't wait to finish the
episode to call me he said he waited to
watch the whole episode before he called
me bro it was heartwarming it was
heartwarming bro he was like
um you guys have done well and say
congratulations to James as well that
you guys are [ __ ] killing it yeah
yeah we won the first like five or ten
minutes just laughing about it like it
was but it was just a happy moment it
was such a happy moment I never would
never would have expected it never would
have accepted it live bro it was
wholesome that's very relaxing wholesome
that's very wholesome I had a wholesome
moment the other day as well I um went
to visit my dad for my sister's birthday
um
and obviously I brought the new car
there yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah
uh and as soon as I got there my brother
was there as well as soon as I went to
the door I said did you bring it
and I said
did you break it on the other side of
the kitchen I'm doing all kisses and
hugs and stuff like that I was like oh
well I was like oh my God he said did
you bring it I was like yeah I'll put it
it's like okay cool oh this that's like
stupid like did you not hear the engine
on my way out you didn't hear me come in
um so yeah yeah so we're chilling and
then my dad's like oh how's this going
how's that going like just talking about
like the show and my business and I was
like yeah yeah it's good it's good it's
good
um and he was like oh cool like any more
shows gonna happen they're just like
General chips yeah yeah and then um I
was like oh do you want it but you want
to see something really cool is what you
said to him yeah you wanna see something
really cool he's like yeah what's that
chucked in my car key oh they said come
outside oh fam I said and he was like
swear but he was cooking and he was like
all right cool like give it a minute
yeah yeah give it a minute give me a
minute fam
anyway my brother's like can we go see
this is like an hour later my brother's
like oh can we go see it I was like yeah
yeah fam
I'm looking
I'm looking for my dad because I was
like I get your shoes and we'll go for a
drive I'm looking for my dad I'm
thinking that oh tell him dad get your
shoes on yeah where's my dad yeah yeah
come on look the front door's open and
swing it
the front door opens yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah found what's out the front and I
see him in the in the windows
glasses on just a joke it was edge up in
the edge up in the windows yeah and he
was like oh it's nice
[Music]
and you could tell like my dad's a man
of very few words
um but you could just tell he was like
this is nice this is a nice car well
done this is very nice guy yeah and yeah
he said like when I left that day he was
like well done I like your car a lot
he's he struggles with compliments my
dad will never never mind I would never
about me like that do you think that's
we're going on a slight tangent here but
do you think that's a cause of his
relationship with his parents oh my dad
grew up without parents oh yes yes yes
my dad doesn't know how to transfer
feelings at all yeah yeah so he tries
his best
um which is nice and he's like I love
very loving guy
um but yeah like because he would look
after he will take care already yeah of
course in terms of like articulation
yeah like you the best you're getting is
about four words but if you get a
wholesome forward it's like you're gas
yeah because you know he means that
because he was like this is a nice car
yeah you're like oh yes yeah yeah yeah
it was nice bro it was real nice and
obviously just me and my brother and my
dad in the car
turbo was turbo yeah wind of my hair
yeah
well in sport mode as well yeah yeah as
soon as because obviously um you drove
you drove us back from London to yours
when I was driving back from yours to
mine I put my thing in sport mode as
well
flying on the m6 James I bet I bet bro
I've been looking for Speed cameras yeah
because I'm just driving too fast yeah
bro yeah yeah yeah dangerously yeah yeah
yeah your thing goes from like 80 to 120
in seconds yeah yeah it's actually scary
is actually scary um I was on it the
other day I put my foot down and you see
when they're like the speedometer goes
up when you when you floor it the tin
goes up like 10 miles an hour at a time
okay not like one two three four five
six seven okay it goes from like 60 bang
to 70. bang to 80. because it can't it's
like you can't keep up yeah yeah mating
um anyway I've got a thread for us today
gang hit me um actually to before I do
the thread before I do the thread um
I've got a couple tweets of the week
I want to keep it consistent yes I like
that I've got a couple tweets of the
week I like that right so let me find
them
found this one sweet image so this is a
little uh this is like a little Tinder
conversation okay so homeboy messaged in
listen to this yeah one guy messaged can
you teach me how to read
the girl replied
that depends what level are you at right
now man replied the [ __ ] does that say
[Music]
S I was not expecting that sweet wow the
[ __ ] does that say foreign
this one sent me home for the night
[Music]
sent me home for the night ma said you
ever nutted so fast you had to explain
like I said see you stay making me wait
you stay making me wet you stay making
me wait this is what happened yeah facts
you don't free me up back free up for me
this is what happens
bro oh my day stay making me wait you're
so painful
the walls are so good if you let me hit
it consistently I will last longer but
if you keep giving me the thumbs once a
week every other week or something like
that I'm gonna not in 10 seconds yeah
it's gonna be a 15 second thing and you
know it's your fault free it up more
often bro 100 this one I've got a couple
right this one said
this one Jarred me
your boyfriend's getting skipped in the
barbershop because he's too scared to
say I was next do better
oh my God that's anxiety peer pressure
so many things robbed wrapped into one
oh he's too scared to say I was next
wow I said you have been there bro hope
so many home juices when I read that I
was like you don't understand how
traumatic that is though oh they will
never understand women don't understand
how true they will never understand how
to make that really is all right
that's those for the day the the [ __ ]
does that say that was so funny that was
so funny comedy gold gold bro comedy
gold
um
wow right so you say you got Freddie
I've got a thread for us now okay
so this one is called this was on Shade
Bar you might have seen it okay so the
the Tweet is
how did you know you weren't gonna get
the job in your interview
so how did you know you weren't gonna
get the job during the interview she's
one girl said when I was given in an
example and I said rare tear no she said
I said
oh wow yeah facts facts
bro yeah she's too used to General where
do you think you are General lingo yeah
where do you switch up you need to
switch up when you step in these four
walls switch up
bro
um
if I'm set when I told him what hours
would suit me
um and I saw him draw a line through my
name
I'm upset what hours are typically best
for you
usually 10 to 12 10 to 2
um
I would have to confront him what was
that did you just cross out my name
sorry did you just cross out my name is
that not what else do you want from me
what do you want me to say that's red
fam that's not fair because no tell me
what you want me to work you asked me
what's best for me I'm just being honest
here I'm flexible I'm flexible basically
what I'm trying to say yeah bro oh
that's hilarious fam when I saw that all
the staff were Asian including the
manager oh wow I just rocked up in this
bare Asians
yeah well I know what's going on yeah
less say less okay
um
fam this one sweeted me yeah when they
asked me to describe myself as an animal
and I said a panda the person next to me
said lion because I'm a leader
wow bro I'll be like why did I say panda
I say ask me again why did I say panda
describe yourself an animal I don't know
like a like a panda like a fluffy Little
Panda what about you I say I'm a lion I
find myself as a leader leader of the
pack I'm a lion king of the jungle oh
you just be sitting there like [ __ ]
far I remember when I was younger I was
an interview
I was facts bro because I remember this
is when uh people used to they say like
you in the interview you need to be
asking them questions it shows you're
interested in fact you need to ask them
questions I went for it this is actually
funny because I obviously I ended up
working at David Lloyd later on but when
I first first caller advisor PT I did an
interview for David Lloyd long like four
stage interview
to be a PT for them
at the last stage it was me and one
other guy and they were like do you have
any more questions for us
fun this brother was asking questions
questions and I didn't I couldn't think
yeah yeah because that's a pressure
thing bro that's a pressure thing I
remember sitting there he was asking all
the perfect questions and they were like
good questions oh no no no no no ask
them
I think I asked him something like how
long is the lunch break
I was crutches straws I was like so
what's the lunch break situation
and they were like safe I think they
literally went 45 minutes
[Music]
were standing up and we were sat down
okay they pulled up a chair next to him
no they not to continue asking questions
I never heard from them again that's the
end of the interview I never heard from
them again I'm not surprised as you
shouldn't I was living as you should I
was [ __ ] how long is the lunch break
that's all I can think of when he's
asking relevant questions he's asking up
payroll he's asking up like client
relations he's asking all sorts and
they're like oh good question good
question pulled up a seat next to him
good good question I couldn't because I
couldn't see that happening to my to my
op while I'm there
question good you know what that's such
an amazing people not enough people ask
questions like that let me put up next
you know because you sound like you got
more yeah and I've got tired let's talk
um ah found this one during the
interview I had to use the bathroom yeah
I thought it would be quick but I was
constipated for half an hour when I came
back they were interviewing the next
person oh Rago raggle
Rago bro
there's an interview in the next just
walked in and they were like oh you're
still here
yeah
I I had I was sitting toilet swear it's
been 30 minutes
what did you expect well you just
thought we were just gonna wait all day
for you oh my [ __ ] goodness get out get
out starting wrong with your mouse get
out get out is this what your toilet
breaks are gonna be like in the job is
it facts
it's embarrassing bro oh I applied for a
job at a tanning so long okay the
manager called me to ask do you tan
often I said no I'm black she hung up
immediately
what Sam I applied for a job at 10 in so
long the manager called me and asked do
you tan often I said no I'm black she
hung up immediately she said you have no
business being here so how are you going
to recommend clients
you don't even need to tan don't waste
my time or my energy take your pigment
and get a different get the [ __ ] out of
here
hung up immediately take your melanin
and look somewhere else
and he paced and he paste some fake
colors that's all I need that's all I
need that's what I need to attract
yeah you are what you eat
you are that's why I need to attract
wow bro that's hilarious I said no I'm
black let me I might as well do the ones
that I had yeah yeah it's the um
first one when I asked that so how did
you know you didn't get the job during
the interview yeah when I asked her to
remind me what position I'd applied for
oh yeah your mom yeah yeah bro yeah get
the [ __ ] out this one fat man said they
were grilling the hell out of me and I
grew tired of it oh
right says whatever in it whoever what
you want to hear I'm saying what you
want to hear cause I don't say it
I'm tired of all these lies try these
questions I'm tired of this facades what
you want to hear I'll say it yeah [ __ ]
say yeah that's pressure I said I grew
tired of it
I can't be asked for this that's
pressure all right I'm gonna run my ones
real quick yeah
um they gave us a coding test I didn't
even understand the question let alone
how to solve it so I started that there
so I started downloading with their
Wi-Fi they caught me no they caught me
tolerance
[Music]
started out anything they caught me
yeah good oh HR asked what do you want
to what do you want to leave well sorry
why do you want to leave your current
job I said I'm looking for better
opportunities she said so if the if a
better opportunity comes while you're
here that means you will leave us I
asked her if a better opportunity comes
won't she leave too
so what happens like so are you
motivated by money yeah yeah yeah so
what happens if another company just
comes along offers you more money oh I'm
not gonna leave because I'm committed to
where because I'm committing a
commitment to you and they're like yeah
[ __ ] off
realize that my CV title had auto
corrected to curriculum vitamin
that's annoying bro that's annoying I
went for a HR intern interview 2018.
they asked where I see myself in five
years I said I see myself working in an
oil company as an environmental analyst
I answered sincerely they asked me to go
home
fun interviewer how well can you perform
Under Pressure me it depends who sang it
yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] nah bro it depends who sang it well
the under pressure
[Laughter]
oh those are the water reserves
as I was leaving
[ __ ] as I was leaving them
it's cool oh my days
right
as I was leaving the inter as I was
leaving the interviewer said I hope it's
not only here you submitted your CV
wow indeed bro that's how you know
you're not getting the job just lie to
me I hope this ain't the only place to
drop the CV my bit my God otherwise
you've wasted your whole life wasted
your whole day
that's not on
they asked me they told me sell it sell
it to me
and the first thing I said was ah I'm
shy
last one I told one of the partners that
I'll be joining her on a commute home
huh
I told him my partners that I'll be
joining her home sorry I'll be joining
her home when she asks how I plan to
commute I'm going to be joining you home
when you're when we're going home
together that's what I'm going to be
doing
get the [ __ ] out that's harassment
and a potential assault get away from me
okay last time the man I had escaped
from at the bar the previous day was my
interviewer I smiled and walked out
laughing
wow that's how you know bro
I'll tell you know it's done wow yeah he
would have been doing up Harvey
Weinstein in there oh God oh God Jesus
oh God yeah yeah yeah yeah
um but yeah that was banging right guys
thank you so much for sticking around as
always come link us on Thursday
patreon.com
we'd love to see it
um and as always guys love love
[Music]
foreign